during the time of me fasting what am i
taking what am i eating is it just water
because you're different things
coffee you can you have juice you can
have all these other things apple juice
what's yours
so water fasting is just that water only
in fact it's distilled water
only fractionally steam distilled water
so the only thing they're getting
during this fasting experience of five
to forty days is water
only now there is juice fast and other
modified programs that people can do
and they can be very helpful but they're
not water fasting water fasting
induces a unique biological adaptation
that's really unique to water fasting
so for the conditions that we're
treating there's nothing that works
quite as well as doing water only
fasting
if you're if you're trying to normalize
blood pressure overcome type 2 diabetes
by reducing insulin resistance
breakdown lymphoma tumors dealing
dealing with
these autoimmune diseases water fasting
is a really unique biological adaptation
water fasting so that means for seven
days all i'm having
is water for anywhere from five to forty
days correct
anywhere between five to forty days all
i'm having is water
and so if you can walk me through this
you know
day one what happens day because you
know the typical one we hear about is
the
18 hour one you start at six o'clock you
don't need to launch 12 o'clock that's
what you hear about 18 hours
you know so what is the
yeah it's the same process but it's
going to be extended out instead of
breaking your fast with breakfast we
would continue now
in our patients let's be clear first
there's review of history exam
and laboratory baseline so we we know
from the history the physical
examination the laboratory testing the
person is a good candidate
that they have the reserves that they
have adequate kidney function they've
got cardiac
stability that we've gotten them weaned
off their medication safely beforehand
and they've done a good lead-in program
so they've eaten fruit salad and steamed
vegetables only for a couple days
there's no meat fish foul eggs dairy
products oil salt sugar highly processed
foods being used
that makes the transition to fasting
much easier and as i said they've been
stabilized off any medications
now they start fasting during the
fasting state we
impose a degree of rest so people can
move around we even have little classes
and things that they do but
basically they're not doing vigorous
exercise or
intense stressful activities and the
reason for that is if you are
extending a water fast and you continue
to say exercise
what you would do is you'd force the
body to generate more glucose to provide
use for the muscle in the brain and the
only place that it can get that glucose
after the glycogen reserves after the
first say 48 hours
is through a process called
gluconeogenesis which is a breakdown of
protein
so we don't want to deplete a patient's
protein reserves we want them to burn
fat and what's really exciting is we
have
actually recently acquired a dexa
scanner
and we've been able to do really
detailed whole body composition changes
and what we've done in this study that
we've that we're publishing
is we've been able to show that visceral
fat
is preferentially mobilized during
fasting not just fat
fat is preferentially mobilized but
specifically visceral fat
so for example a person might lose 20
percent of their total body fat during
fasting but they may lose 40 to 60
percent of their visceral fat
so the body is actually going in and
mobilizing this um
fat that tends to accumulate around the
core and in around the organs that's
thought to be most associated with
compromised health
it'll mobilize visceral fat first and
preferentially
and then it will mobilize adipose tissue
and then it will preserve protein
so that when you look at the weight
that's lost during fasting let's say a
person loses say 20 pounds
some of that's fat some of it's protein
some of it's glycogen
some of its fiber that was in the gut
some of its fluids
and then when they come off the fast
they regain weight but the weight that's
regained
during recovery is almost exclusively
protein water fiber and glycogen and not
fat in fact the fat loss continues
during re-feeding
and so what we found with water only
fasting is it's a unique
unique way of mobilizing visceral fat
which helps open up blood vessels gets
rid of the health compromising
components
much more so than say going on a high
protein high fat
keto type diet you know the fasting men
making diets which can blood hunger and
facilitate weight loss
that may have some short-term benefit
may have some long-term serious
consequences
just like with water fasting you
wouldn't water fast forever
you water fast for a period of time and
then you go back to eating a health
promoting diet
but the net effect on the body is to
reverse to
reverse visceral fat normalize blood
pressure
uh it reduces insulin resistance which
allows diabetics to normalize their
blood sugar levels it breaks down
some of the masses for example a person
might lose 10 percent of their body
weight
but they won't lose 10 percent of their
tumor they may lose 50
or 100 percent of their mass because the
body's preferentially mobilizing tissues
in inverse proportions of their need
and that's why visceral fat tumors
growth other things sometimes go away in
fasting
um disproportionate to the percentage of
weight that the body loses